تنضمي الينا من البصره مراسله صباح
العربيه زين الاجانب المشاط زينب يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك تاخذين اليوم تجربه فريده
يعني نستكشف معك اهلا بك نستشرف معك اخت
صدام حسين الغارق في الشط العرب
زينب تسمعيني
نعم في الواقع انا اظهر اليوم نعم اسمعك
اسمعك فقط الرياح يعني حركت القارب الذي
يقف عليه المصور
انا اظهر اليوم من على احد اجزاء يخت
المنصور في شط العرب جنوبي البصره طبعا
كنا نروي ان نقف على سطح هذا اليخت لكن
للاسف في الرياح اليوم تجري على عكس ما
نشتهي طبعا هذا اليخت صنع في ثمانينيات
القرن الماضي في فنلندا عام وارسل الى
العراق عام 1983 يبلغ طوله 121 متر
ويعني وزنها يبلغ 7000 طن تقريبا طبعا هذا
اليخت يعد واحد من اهم واضخم اليخوت التي
كان يملكها صدام حسين والتي هي تقدر
بحوالي ثلاثه يخوض تقريبا هذا اليخت كان
يرسه في ميناء ام قصر حتى عام 2003 قرر
صدام حسين رساله الى ممرشط العرب في اذار
ثلاثه نعم طبعا خشيه على اليخت من القصف
الامريكي لكن للاسف الخطه الخطه فشلت
وتعرض القصف بعد ذلك في اذار 2003 اليخت
الى القصف على مدى ثلاث ايام متتاليه لكن
هذا القصف يعني لم يتسبب بغرق اليخت كما
ذكرت مفتشيه اثار البصره ما تسبب بغرق
اليخت هو سرقه المضخات الضخمه الموجوده في
محركات هذا اليخت والتي ادت الى حدوث ثقوب
كبيره جدا وتسربت المياه في اليخت فبدا
اليخت بالميلان تحديدا في يونيو 2003 طبعا
كما نشاهد اليخت اليوم يعني هو هيكل صدق
ومتهالك يتواجد في يعني يقف في منتصف شط
العرب وهو اليوم يعني مزار للسياح
والصيادين ايضا الحكومه المحليه في البصره
تنوي حسب ما يقال تفكيك هذا اليخت وتقسيمه
الى اجزاء وانتشاله من شط العرب لكن هذا
الامر يتطلب مبالغ كبيره جدا جدا نعم يا
زينب اول شغله اسمحي لي انه انا احييك
يعني هذا اللايف مميز جدا وجودك الان في
البصره في جنوب العراق وعلى هذا الهيكل
الهيكل الذي يعني يتحدث عن تاريخ ويتحدث
عن حقبه زمنيه وسياسيه في العراق الان انت
تقفين على هذا القارب وفي مكان خطر يعني
نتمنى لك السلامه وايضا الكاميرا مان
وقطعتي الساعات سفر من البصره حتى من
بغداد حتى تصل الى البصره نحييك اولا على
هذا الامر وايضا يعني رغم المواقف
السياسيه اليوم من قبل المشاهدين بحقبه
صدام حسين الى انه لا نستطيع ولا احد ينكر
بان الان ما نشاهده هذه الصور هي مشاهد
فعلا يعني تستحق النظر يعني مشاهد تعيد
بنا الزمن الى الوراء بنا تساؤلات كثيره
واليوم نحن يعني اتوقع زينب باننا ننفرد
بهكذا انواع من المباشر
بهكذا نوع من المباشر يعني كان في اخبار
مثلا بالوكالات وبالصحف فقط هم ينشرون صور
لهذا القارب الذي يطفو في شط العرب في
البصره ولكن عندما نتحدث عن هذا المباشر
اعتقد بانه صباح العربيه يعني انفرد قبل
غيره من المحطات في هكذا ظهور لو ايضا
تخبرين زينب بالنسبه للخطط يعني ماذا يمكن
ان يفعل يعني بدات بالحديث بانه سمعتي
معلومات فيما يتعلق بالخطط الحكوميه
للبصره كماذا سيفعل بهذا الهيكل وما مصيره
يعني اذا كان يطفو ونصف غارقا
نعم نادين يعني بالبدايه هذا اليخت يعني
يعتبره العراقيون فعلا جوهره ثمينه
متواجده في شط العرب المشكله ان الانتشار
اليخت من النهر يتطلب مبالغ ضخمه قد تصل
الى اكثر من المبالغ التي صرفت على يعني
صناعته فهذا ما يحول دون انتشاله بسهوله
لكن الحكومه المحليه تعمل على ذلك يعني
هنالك انباء يعني عن محاولات قريبه جدا
لتفكيك اليخت وانتشاله غير معلوم حتى الان
يعني ماذا يرمون يعني الفعل به بعد
انتشاله واخراجه من الشاطئ حاليا هذا
الامر غير معلوم لكن على بعد 500 متر من
هذا اليخت يتواجد يخت اخر لصدام حسين هو
وهي خط رئاسي اخر يعني هو ياخذ نسيم
البصره على بعد 500 متر من الان
يعني هذا اليخت هو حاليا مركز لعلوم
البحار وهو ايضا يتضمن متحف لما كان
يتضمنه في السابق يعني لمقتنيات الرئيس
ونحن زينب نشكرك جزيل الشكر وايضا نشير
بانه اليوم عشرون عاما ايضا على الحرب في
العراق واسقاط نظام صدام حسين اليوم ايضا
هذه المشاهد وهذه الصور للقارب الغارق
الذي يطفو في شط العرب تتزامن ايضا مع
مرور 20 عاما لحرب العراق شكرا جزيلا لك
من البصره مراسله صباح العربيه زينب مشط